[Applause]
you wouldn't believe you would not
believe how insane
it is outside i i know i've talked about
this a few times but the uh that that
rockefeller center christmas tree you've
all checked this out on the way in it's
a major tourist attraction
apparently these people not interested
at all in that tree
this is huge tuesday night they had the
big tree lighting ceremony
just just a couple of feet from where i
sit right now here in rockefeller center
and it was a big big event take a look
at that i think people
from all over the world came and saw
this thing and there it went yeah
lit up and very nice yeah
then a very drunk al roker apparently
hillary duff and jessica simpson were
all singing and swaying in time to the
music
it was really the lights were
spectacular people were very excited
about it
but for me i gotta say the christmas
season didn't really begin until last
night
when we held our first ever late night
stump lighting ceremony
that's right this is big people forget
about the stump
there's the tree the beautiful 71-foot
tree that's outside rockefeller center
but what about the stump
that held that mighty tree all those
years but we did it live from suffer new
york in rockland county
home of the stump for this year's
rockford center christmas tree
and here's a clip from how it went last
night there you see it right there and
uh yeah there it was
there's tom cruise and a couple of other
celebrities and yeah
that was samuel jackson uh tom cruise
and holly shore all together
only the camera had panned up for a
second
what a waste of that incredible talent
we got anyway well
folks i'll tell you something i thought
the christmas tree stump would become a
major tourist attraction
after we did that last night i was
convinced that all everybody everybody
on the east coast would flock to see the
stump
this is unbelievable i've been told that
nobody has gone to see the stunt
not one person has visited the christmas
stump
i cannot believe this this is
unfathomable to me the only thing i can
think
is that excited tourists just don't know
exactly how to find the stump that must
be the answer i think a lot of people
want to go they just don't know how to
get there
well folks the stump is only minutes
from manhattan it's very simple so get
your pen and paper out
just take route 87 north for 12 miles to
exit 8a
go west four miles and turn left at the
third light park in the lot behind the
chicken shack and head into the woods
for 1.2 miles
across the stream just past old man
porter's place watch out that guy's
crazy and you're there it's very easy so
go see the stump can you see the stump
one more time
let's see that stump stump there we go
see now
and go fast because once those crowds
form you will not be able to get close
enough to the stump
to see it all right
i love these awkward silences that one
was better than the first one all right